We're with Raymond Ibrahim and are you
still with Middle East Forum as a fellow
writer fellow? I am Middle East Forum,
Gatesstone Institute and some other
institutes and so forth and author of
how many books now? Well uh um I haven't
actually thought about that. So let's
see the alqaeda eater and uh crucified
again and sword and scimitar defenders
of the west and the new book two swords
of Christ and my master's thesis the
battle of yarmmuk is actually now also
available. So we can say six books six
books.
And the new one's coming out when it's
coming out November 25th, but you can
pre-order it now. Okay. So, we'll talk
about that in a little bit. And I love
Sword and Son. Thank you. That That was
meaty stuff. Tell me why.
I'm putting you on the spot. Well,
you're putting me on the spot, but I I
think it's because there's not a lot out
there. I was talking about the military
history, number one, right? And um that
this is not a peaceful religion. It has
never been a peaceful religion, right?
And here's the evidence. Let's go
through it and let's look at what
history has shown us, right? And I think
that's I think that was the key thing.
Before I wrote surah and simitar, what
we had is a lot of people who criticized
Islam as a religion and they said it was
intolerant and violent, but they
couldn't back it up historically. They
would just cite Muhammad saying this,
the Quran saying that, but they couldn't
really show the history. And I think
from what I've understood from the
feedback is the success of sword and
scimitar is it showed you that okay
forget about all what the musty dusty
old scriptures say and let's see what
Muslims did and lo and behold for
centuries they did exactly what the
scriptures said. So it it is it's a
manifestation of what the the abstract
scripture said of violence intolerance
towards Christians and infidels. But now
you have a documented peace meal century
by century. And I think that ultimately
from the feedback I've gotten is what
really opened people's eyes. And that
book's done very well. It's done. Yeah,
that's done very well. It's uh every
year it actually sells more copies than
previous years, which is rare for a book
because usually a book gets out. Yeah.
The first year is bloom and then it
declines. This has been the opposite. As
people read it, word gets out. Hey, you
really want a serious uh look at this?
Here's the book for you. I'm grateful
for that. Yeah. Well, good. God's
blessed you with that. Uh but it was a
lot of hard work. People don't realize
how hard it is. It was literally 20
years of work because uh the you know it
centers around several battles and the
first battle chapter one the battle of
Yarmmuk was actually my master's thesis
uh when I was under Victor Davis Hansen
back in Fresno State literally 23 25
years ago. So I really built up on that
my master's thesis battle of the Arnuk
which was so powerful and important and
consequential became chapter one. But in
the intervening years until I started
writing sword and scimitar, I started
studying all the major battles and uh
when I was living here in DC at the
library of congress, I actually acquired
a lot of primary sources in various
languages that and you have a lot of
sources that you can't find anywhere
else. So I think that's what really
beefed it up and it's amazing though.
I'm glad it's doing so well. Appreciate
that. Uh as I liked your previous ones.
Thank you. Yeah. Yeah. There's fight
again. There's a fight again. Yeah.
Yeah. Uh that was excellent. Um it's
interesting too to see the continuity
because you know crucified again that's
a subtitle exposing Islam's new born
Christians was about the modern era
Muslim day persecution of Christians and
then when you let's go to sword and
scimitar which is about history and then
you find the continuities and you see
that what's happening in crucified again
or what's happening to Christians in the
modern era by Muslims actually has a
long paper trail that goes back 14
centuries. And so at that point and
here's here's the importance I think of
all this put together. It's not a
coincidence. We can't say that something
that happened in the 7th century and
Muslims were citing Muhammad and the
Quran saying this that and the other
thing visav Christians and you can fast
forward 14 centuries and it's the same
exact thing. Okay. So I I think that was
the importance to show how one's about
the modern era, one's about history, but
guess what? They all complement each
other and show you a very full picture.
And Raymond, when you expose all this,
you get labeled an Islamophobe. Well, of
course, because I'm speaking the truth
and uh I'm going against a narrative. As
you know, in our society and our
culture, there's certain narratives and
archetypes that can't be challenged. And
this is one of them. Uh it's not just
that you can't challenge Islam. That's
bad enough. But to say Christians are
the good guys, that's even doubly bad
because Christians, as we all know, are
white people. And white people by nature
and white Christians, medieval
Christians are evil. And you know, the
the tolerant non-whites of the Middle
East and the Islamic world are the good
guys. And this is why I always talk
about what I call fake history. You
know, a lot of people we know fake news
and it's dangerous. Fake history is so
much more dangerous. It's so much more
subtle than fake news because it creates
overarching narratives and then you see
reality. You see everything that happens
today through that fake prism. So if you
think Christians are the aggressors,
they're racists, they're colonialists,
be vis, the crusades, and then you fast
forward to today, then of course the
arguments that people today, you know,
the Hamas protype people makes sense,
right? And that's why it was created.
That's why this fake history
predominates and it's why it's so
important to debunk it. I I want to talk
about that in a in a moment. Sure.
Because of how what's happening on our
college campuses right now, right?
Because it's very dangerous. People
don't realize how dangerous that really
is for the future, not just now, but the
future of the American mind. Right.
Right. Um, but you wrote an article, I
think earlier this year, where you were
talking about the left and victimization
and and using the the Muslims uh and
justifying the victimization
uh that way and Muslims becoming
victims, right? Uh, explain a little bit
more about that article. Sure. Well, in
general, it's it's this idea that a lot
of people have noticed, which is this
the the two strange bedfellows, the
left, as we call them in Islam, right,
who by nature, especially the latter,
Islam, despises what we call the left,
which is, you know, sheer liberalism,
right? LGBT, homosexuality, all the
liberal stuff you can think about, which
is so antithetical to Islam. But they
happen to be in cahoots and in the same
bed which it in and of itself is so
revealing when you think about it
because it just shows you it goes back
to the idea of you know the enemy of my
enemy is my friend and it's yeah they
hate each other but their greater enemy
is Christians and Christendom and the
idea of Christianity and so you find the
left and that whole jaundist realm which
I don't like the word the left I think
it's so generic I think we can call it
something better and I think it
legitimizes them because it presupposes
a continuum of the middle which is
objective and the right which is a
little kind of extreme and the left
which is a little extreme but what the
left is today is just satanic I think
right it's beyond politics it's beyond a
view it's just really unhinged to be
generous well I make a distinction
between leftists and liberals people who
truly believe in liberalism well
classical liberalism you know Steuart
John Stewart you and and those u yeah
exactly and they get conflated
unfortunately
But at the same time, I believe that in
as much as the liberals of the 19th
century and uh or earlier um you know
meant well and you and I can sympathize
with so much of this in a way like that
was still the kernel that led to
full-blown leftism because what they did
is they started doubting tradition
traditional Christianity and once you
open that door and again from a secular
secular point of view we can agree you
as Christians we can agree that you can
opened the door a little bit, but it
just seems like once you open the door a
little bit, it didn't close. Yeah. Like
if you look at the homosexuality thing I
was amazed the other, you know, recently
I watched a video uh made by a school
public school district in California in
California no less warning children
about homosexuality and it was a it's a
commercial. It's black and white and
it's you know the words they even use
are very offensive. It's derogatory. you
know, it's like the way they what how
they present homosexuals. And it's just
amazing to me that like, okay, and that
was, you know, that was one thing. And
then in the 70s, the rehabilitation,
let's say, of homosexuality started. And
in and of itself, it seemed reasonable
to a liberal, right? Because it was
like, look, I just have my life. I'm not
I don't do mine. I'm in. Yeah. Don't
bother me. And people accepted that. But
it didn't end there, right? And it kept
morphing and morphing and morphing until
now. I can't even identify a man and a
woman and I have to, you know, pervert
my knowledge of pronouns and it's gotten
really warped and sick. And it reminds
me of the boiling frog syndrome, right?
You know, if if if in the 60s Yeah. If
in the 60s when I was talking about
where they were openly warning against
homosexuality, let's say in that time
our woke crowd came and said, "Hey, you
know, you can't call me a I'm a I'm a
man, not a sir." and all that, it
wouldn't have worked cuz it would be
throwing the frog in boiling water. But
they did it very gradually and slowly
and and uh you know accustomed us to the
heat and now we're at this point and now
we are actually accepting it. A lot of
people accept it and so that's the left
and we're talking about Islam as well.
But Islam I think to them is sort of
like the foot soldier because going back
to what I was saying the ultimate enemy
is Christianity Christian war aids
Christian ethics and uh who common enemy
common that's the common enemy for both
so the left as we call them will empower
Islam because that's the foot soldier
against the common enemy and one of the
greatest uh ironies that happened
recently maybe you're familiar with this
I don't know how to pronounce this hamr
hamric yeah missing vowel I'm from
Michigan, so I don't need a vowel
somewhere, but used to be a Catholic
Polish community, right? Predominant.
Now it's Yeah, it's majority Muslim. And
the people that helped them were the
leftists and the LGBT crowd and they
voted for them. And now that the city
council is a majority Muslim, first
thing they did is cancel pride,
gay pride stuff. And the Muslim and the
leftists were felt betrayed. But that
that right there is a microcosm of what
you can expect. Okay, you want to help
them? Sure, they'll use you and uh you
know, you're the last one they'll deal
with. But and in Ham Tramik, you can
hear the call to prayer. Uh the city
council years ago voted in favor of
allowing them to have the call to prayer
on their loudspeakers. But there were
complaints about churches ringing their
bell. Exactly. And if you were an
evangelical and you were a pastor going
out on the streets and street preaching,
you'd run into a little trouble there.
Exactly. That's okay to have. Isn't that
ironic? Yeah. Yeah. And that just shows
you the sort of I I don't want to you
know diabolical animist for the truth
i.e. Christianity and we'll take
something that's even worse for us as a
people as a community as homosexuals and
we'll accept that because we just hate
the other thing Christianity. So I think
that ultimately is the uh connection
between the left and Islam. Well, what I
find interesting is you have these LGBTQ
groups uh on college campuses with the
pro Hamas crowd, right? The Palestinians
gays for Gaza. Gays for Gaza. It's like,
are you kidding me? Do Do you know what
would happen to you in Gaza under Hamas
if you went there and lived there? How
long you would live? Not very long,
would they? And that's just again it's a
reflection not so much of that they
sympathize with Gazins or Muslims or
Palestinians but that they hate the
Judeo-Christians
you know and they reject that strain. So
we will side with whoever you know what
I mean and exactly you're gays under
Islam get thrown off a roof because
that's how they can simulate uh the the
hail falling down Sodom Gomorrah in the
Islamic rendition. And uh so yeah, again
it's it's just it just shows you that
you know as the years have passed by one
of the things that have actually
strengthened my faith in Christianity
and this is such a weird route for me
hasn't been because I read the Bible
more. It hasn't been because I had a
special experience. It's kind of my
knowledge of history and piecing
together what's happening today. And
I've never seen such a benign ideology
i.e. Christianity that is so altruistic
and so helpful and has done demonstrably
good things being bombarded from every
single angle and so hated from every
single angle. That to me has been one of
the most potent proofs of its veracity.
Does that make sense? Yes. And the Jews
run into that too because uh I mean look
the covenant that Abraham had with God
or God had with Abraham is still in
existence and as covenant people right
because we have the new covenant which
is just an extension and fulfillment of
the old as as believers as Christians.
Uh so who are they going to go after?
Judeo-Christian people, right? And
that's that's who they to be fair to be
fair, they kill everyone who's an
infidel. But of course, and which is
ironic because the Judeo-Christians and
Jews and Christians are the people of
the book, which supposedly makes us even
safer than the infid. In other words,
and that's safety. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
Exactly. So, we just attended a
conference here, right? Washington DC.
That's why I'm saying the irony is, you
know, like we're supposed to be still
discriminated and attacked and fought,
but not as much as, let's say, a pagan
or a Hindu, but in reality on the
ground, it's the opposite. Yeah. They
they attack Hindus in India. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, let's talk a little bit
about the college campuses and what's
happening there. What do what do you
think the long-term effect ish
of these pro- Hamas, pro Palestinian?
Okay. I'm the one who Yeah. who revealed
years ago that Qatar was the chief uh
yeah financeier of a lot of these
colleges and the irony to me it's not
just Qatar Saudi Arabia um other Muslim
countries China and you have to ask
yourself all right these are all
authoritarian Islamist dictatorial
governments who would never allow their
people to have freedom of thought and
here they are spending billions because
they care about the fine arts in America
and they want to make a contribution
It's in other words, it's so flagrantly
off obvious what they're doing. They are
paying to make sure we believe a
narrative that supports them and not us
fundamentally. And it's kind of shameful
that that that it could even happen.
Billions of dollars, billions, billions
of dollars. And so that's why you see
what you're seeing in the campuses. When
I went to Georgetown University a long
time ago, and I believe it's much worse
now, not just in Georgetown, but in all
these other colleges that have been
popping up and you know, red flags with
them is um everything well of course
what I'm talking about, forget about it.
But you know, everything began and ends
with Israel. They're the root source of
everything. And it's presented in a way
in a vacuum, okay? as if before the
creation of Israel in 47 or 48 4 at that
time that as if before that everything
was just fine Muslims were living
wonderfully they were affluent and
everything and it's kind of and that's
and this is what they do with
Christianity too so when they talk about
the crusades for example they make it
sound like five everything before the
crusades was nice you know what I mean
and then yeah so this is the same exact
trick and the same exact lie that they
they're trying to play but all those
millions and billions that come from
these
Salifist Wahhabi nations are dedicated
to promoting
themselves and demonizing their enemies
which would be of course Israel, Western
civilization and Christendom. And it's
unfortunate that it's so effective but
we are seeing the repercussions right
now and Trump has some big deals that he
had recently with the Qataris right
and also the Saudis uh in the US
investing in the US. Is that a good
thing or a good thing? Well, time will
tell. Are they going to actually, you
know, step up to the bargain or is this
a little exploitation? Obviously, the
latter has happened very much under
Muslim rulers and Muslim governance
because it's actually legitimate for
Muslims to deceive the infidel because
in Islam basically, and here's another
thing they share with the left, the end
justifies the means. So there's unlike
with Christians, you know, the means is
very important to them, the end
justifies it. So if the end is helping
Islam run over the world, which is good
from their perspective, then we can lie,
cheat, and steal, you know, just like
this is how the left stick as well. So I
think a lot of that is going on, which
is why, you know, the deals ostensively
could and potentially can be good, but
time will tell if they actually stick to
it. I know that what is happening now in
the Middle East is very relevant uh to
your book, your new one that is coming
out in about 6 months. Tell tell us I
know you've been working on that heart.
Tell us a little about it. Yeah. Yeah.
Thanks, Gary. It is and that's the
irony. You know, I to me I always see
things in a very holistic way. So, I
write about things from over a thousand
years ago and then what we're talking
about and I can see the connections.
It's it's I always see I love tracing
continuities cuz to me that is one of
the best ways to demonstrate a proof, a
truth, a veracity. You know, when you
see if it's happening constantly, you
think, you know, I don't care if the
book, the scripture says this or
doesn't. If people are acting that way
always and in different iterations, not
just Arabs, not just Persians, not just
Turks, Muslims, then you know it's an
Islamic thing. But um yeah, so thank
you. My my new book, which is coming out
soon, is already written. It's and it
can be pre-ordered. It's called The Two
Swords of Christ, and the subtitle is
Five Centuries of War between the
Warrior Monks of Christendom and Islam.
And it's about the military orders,
specifically the Templars and the
Hospitalers, because their story, for
someone like me who's a historian who
knows their story and at the same time
knows how they're presented in the
modern era, especially the Templars,
they've been so, you know, pulled out of
context and demonized and turned into
something that they would just be, you
know, it would be ah horrent for them to
even see. And it's and in the book, I
actually address it. And I I don't quote
myself. I I bring you serious historians
who address the topics of the Templars.
But at any rate, these guys uh for them,
which is funny because us as Christians
and um and this is one of the points I
wanted to bring out is so the book's
title is the two swords of Christ. What
am I referring to? On the surface, I'm
referring to the Templars and and the
hospitalers because they were the two
swords of Christ. But more literally, I
mentioned that verse and we'll and I'll
paraphrase it. It's a verse where
basically um Jesus sells sell your shirt
and buy a sword and the disciples say
look Lord we have two and he says that
is enough in in the modern day exug
Jesus it's sort of been allegorized into
nothingness okay it's not about any
sword or defense or anything but to
preodern and especially medieval
Christians what it meant is that we have
two swords are enough because we need
one sword to fight spiritual enemies and
one sword to fight physical enemies and
that's how what that's the rational of
the Crusades, the second sword. Okay?
And so, and this was actually
non-negotiable. And and you can
understand why because for preodern
Christians and medieval Christians, they
were under attack constantly. It's easy
for us modern Christians to sit back and
say, "Oh, you shouldn't fight back when
I never get attacked." But when you're
living in a in a realm, your women and
children are being killed and you have
to fight back. And the irony is, and
this is why I wanted to write it, is the
two groups, the Templars and the
Hospitalers, and they weren't just
regular Christians. They weren't just
crusaders. They would their origins are
these were the most pious aesthetic men.
Okay. So, especially the hospitalers in
their origins all they were this is the
first origin of the idea of a hospital.
Okay. And there they had a phrase which
is our lords the sick. So they were
devoted to healing the sick, protecting
the sick, feeding the sick, bathing the
sick, bandaging the sick, giving the
sick their beds. Okay, this is who they
were. And isn't it ironic that that kind
of Christian also became the most
militant Christian. But it wasn't ironic
in a sense because if you understand
what was happening, they understood that
rather than wait for Christians who were
coming to pilgrimage in the holy land
and that's where they were based to get
mauled and attacked and killed by
Muslims cuz that's what was happening.
We are going to preempt it. We are going
to protect them with the sword with the
second sword which is Christ said two
swords are enough. And so I just find it
fascinating that you had these kinds of
Christians who and the same thing with
the templars. They just wanted to
protect the routes of pilgrims. Okay.
And they just gave their lives up and
the holy sites. Yeah. Exactly. And the
holy sites in Jerusalem and all
throughout the holy land. And if the the
verses that they quote and that actuated
them, okay, would be that. But they also
unlike modern day Christians were very
obsessed with the Old Testament. It
applied to them. And as you know, the
Old Testament, for lack of a better
word, is militant in a righteous way.
Just just read kings and chronicles. And
one of their favorite verses that ODA
would always recite is because they were
always outnumbered, the military or and
in the end towards the end of the
crusader era, it was just them cuz all
the other regular secular crusaders were
either gone and just couldn't deal with
it. So you just had this hardcore group
of and it was literally in the battles,
it would be like one verse 100. And so
one of the verses in Deuteronomy that
actuated to them is the one that says
one man, how could it be one man will
drive a thousand and two men will put
10,000 to flight. So it's very
interesting to me that today they
they're dismissed and not true not true
Christians, but they were so obsessed
with scripture. They saw themselves
still living and walking in the foot
paths both of the Old and the New
Testament. And I think the lesson for
modern day Christians is you don't have
to be a doormat. And uh I think how did
how did it come to that? How do we get
to this doormat? Yeah, we're waiting for
that uh that way of thinking. You know
what I think uh Gary? I think um for the
longest time I just thought that okay,
obviously in the New Testament in
Christ's words in the apostles, you have
what we would call passive behavior,
forgiveness, tolerance, it's all there
and that is Christian and that should be
done. I would never argue against that.
But it's been pulled out of context and
it's sort of become the pinnacle of
Christianity. You know, Jesus is the
same man who also after preaching all
that who went into a temple and hurled
tables and wicked people. Okay, there's
righteous indignation. You know, he
defended and when he talked uh you know
when we all know what what does Jesus do
when people uh when he does a commits a
miracle for them? He tells them repent,
right? Because they're sinners. He
didn't tell the centurion to repent. He
didn't tell him get out of the army. He
actually said, "I haven't found a man
with so much faith." And uh when the
soldiers came to John the Baptist and he
also said, "Repent." And they were being
baptized and they said, "What must we
do?" He said, "Be content with your
wages." He didn't say, "Quit the ro quit
the army cuz you're murderers." So I
think we've lost this idea that to be a
Christian, you know, you defending that
which is right, good, and true in your
in your loved ones, in your in your
nation, in your cultural heritage is 100
legit. 100% legit. But they I think
there's this evil force that has
convinced Christians and it's pulled out
a contest because if you're an enemy of
Christianity, okay, let's say I hate
Christians, whatever. I'm an atheist.
I'm a Satanist. Would I not I would and
let's say I'm a millionaire billionaire.
I would spend billions of dollars
convincing Christians that your religion
is all about nothing else than turning
the other cheek and forgiving and never
judging because how else can you run
rough shot on a people other than
getting them to do it themselves? Yeah.
If they accept that, then you can run.
Yeah. Then I control you. Okay. And um
and then the worst part I think and this
is a a thought a thought that's been
growing with me is you know to what
extent do men especially today are they
turning the other cheek because it's
it's hard for them to do that but they
want to they want to obey the Lord's
command or are they cowards by nature
and they're justifying their craven
behavior. Okay. Because what is it that
today's Western men and Christian men
they're not confrontational. They don't
want to get in someone's face. They
don't want to judge. What's wrong with
judging? We all judge. Judge is to
essentially discriminate good from bad,
right? What's wrong with that in my
head? They don't want to do that. They
don't want to essentially confront evil.
Okay? So, are you really doing that
because you're obeying Christ or are you
a coward and you found a pious pretext
to hide under? And I think a lot of
that's been going on and that needs
really shaking up. And I think one of
the reasons I wrote that book actually
is to show you no that's not how it was.
These guys sacrificed their lives dying
for their fellow man. And they never
once thought this isn't Christian or I'm
not a good Christian because I'm engaged
in violence. They understood like you
said look at the Old Testament and all
the militancy and the righteous wrath
that's involved and even Jesus himself
and so forth. So I think that is really
missing and I think that's really by
design too by our enemies. How do you
think the book is going to be received
by military? Well, I think they'll like
it, especially if they're a Christian.
They like the Latin, they like,
not all of them. Yeah. Yeah. But, uh,
no, I think rank and wild. Yeah. I think
it is. If you're a Christian, I think
it's going to speak to a lot of
Christian men who have been so browbe
into thinking that to be a good
Christian, you have to be a woman. I
don't know how to put it better than
that, but I think there's this
atmosphere today amongst Western
Christians where if you want to be a
good Christian, you just have to be
masculine. You know what I mean? Well,
they've emasculated Jesus. Yeah.
Exactly. Well, yeah. That's what the
culture, right? Right. And he's No, I'm
sorry. He was very masculine. The real
Jesus, you know, but he's been pulled
out of context and weaponized to
emasculate Christian men. And I think
it's high time for that to change. I'm
looking forward to the book. I
appreciate that. It's a it's actually a
trilogy. So sword and scimitar which
you're familiar with is the first one
and then that came out in 2018 and the
defenders of the west the Christian
heroes against Islam came out in 2022.
And the difference between those two
books is sword and scimitar looked at
eight decisive battles that really were
changing. Defenders of the west as I
often put it looked at eight decisive
men who didn't play around against
Islamic aggression. This book is kind of
this is the most violent of them all,
which is ironic because it was
spearheaded by the most pious men of
all. I mean, these guys were clustered
monks who when not fighting were fasting
and praying like 8 hours a day. I mean,
this is really like stuff that's hard
for a modern day Christian to wrap their
heads around. And I just think it's
refreshing, at least as an example, to
see that this sort of thing actually
existed and it really rocked the world.
And the reason they lost in the end was
numbers. So the, you know, the verse I
quoted, Deuteronomy, one man, you know,
it literally got to that point where it
was worse because all the secular
crusaders fled the holy night and the
only guys that were there were the
warrior monks and they would literally
it would be, you know, a ratio of one to
like 100 fighting against Muslims and
they eventually lost. It was impossible.
Well, Raymond Ibrahim, we we appreciate
talking with you and look forward to
that book. Likewise. Thank you. Thanks,
Gary. I had a good time. Thank